[Musique]
en vue de le DPE l'observatoire
départemental de la protection de
l'enfance le département organisé des
réunions de travail sur le thème des
violences intrafamiliales
l'année dernière les associations
c'était important aujourd'hui de pouvoir
fédérer tous les partenaires pour
pouvoir tout construire ensemble un plan
d'action en fait sur la thématique des
violences intrafamilales le département
fait de cette question une priorité de
sa mandature donc chacun avec son
expertise est venue
réfléchir ensemble pour pouvoir mettre
en place ce plan d'action on a travaillé
aujourd'hui autour de trois axes et un
trois thématiques la première c'est
comment est-ce qu'on repère pour pouvoir
aller vers les personnes qui sont
victimes de violence la deuxième c'est
la communication la sensibilisation et
donc le troisième axe qui est les
besoins fondamentaux et les droits de
l'enfant les chiffres qui ne cessent
d'augmenter les violences
intrafamiliales un sujet au coeur des
préoccupations pour les institutions et
associations on a cette réunion qui nous
a indiqué beaucoup de chiffres à un
détaillés des pourcentages on a une
augmentation
de violence de maltraitance sur les
tout-petits les petits enfants à 0,3 ans
mais on le voit de toute façon nous à
l'écoute chaque jour des familles qui
arrivent soit par les réseaux sociaux
soit par le téléphone de PA on a
effectivement ce même constat ça
augmente alors ça augmente mais en même
temps je pense que les chiffres qui nous
qui ont été donnés par le département ne
sont pas
comment dire il faut pas en avoir peur
parce que ça montre une libération aussi
de la parole une augmentation des
plaintes la fin d'un tabou par exemple
sur l'inceste clairement la honte change
de camp on a mené des actions depuis
quelques années donc ces chiffres là oui
reflètent une réalité alors il y a des
des dommages que latéraux dans tout ce
qui ressentent soit ce sont des
agressions
physiques qui peuvent recevoir lors de
ces violences ou soit ce sont des
agressions psychologiques et qui peuvent
faire des dommages qui peuvent perdurer
toute une vie si c'est pas pris en
charge
et qui menace leur équilibre et qui
menacent leur développement surtout sur
le très jeune enfant
les services départementaux de l'aide
sociale à l'enfance met en oeuvre
diverses actions afin de prévenir et
repérer les situations de danger ou de
risque de danger
nous avons au département
une cellule de recueil des informations
préoccupantes cette cellule centralise
ces informations préoccupantes et
les transmets au territoire concernés en
fonction de du lieu de vie de l'autorité
parentale de ses enfants et nous sommes
chargés d'évaluer ces situations là
une mise en commun des compétences très
appréciée par l'ensemble des partenaires
alors je pense que notre partenariat
avec le département enrichit nos
pratiques professionnelles et va aussi
permettre à nos professionnels d'être
plus efficaces par le biais de
protocoles et de travaux menés en commun
qu'on va pouvoir leur partager
je pense qu'on travaille tous dans le
même sens mais on travaille chacun de
notre côté donc il est un peu imagé la
chose on plante chacun notre petite
graine dans notre jardin il faudrait
faire un potager commun pour qu'on
puisse vraiment lutter contre ce fléau
pour les violences contre les enfants
surtout les témoins de violence
il y a une vraie volonté de secteur
associatif comme des institutionnels à
travailler sur des possibilités de
réponse c'est sur la sensibilisation
qu'il y a à faire sur ce sujet on sent
bien qu'il y a un véritable intérêt à
une mobilisation partagée pour assurer
une meilleure prise en compte de ces
situations d'enfants exposées aux
violences intraphes
une restitution de ces travaux a eu lieu
lors de l'odpe le 22 juin dernier ou le
président a présenté son plan d'action
pour prévenir et lutter contre les
violences intrafamiliales la première
phase c'est d'accentuer les actions de
prévention revenir c'est quoi ces
détecter les situations de violence
et on le fait à travers le réseau
d'association à travers les PMI puisque
on le sait bien le département dispose
batteur réseau de travail associés
infirmier médecin au sein des PMI qui
sont déployés sur tout le territoire
pour favoriser la détection des
situations de violence on travaille
aussi avec le rectorat et nous voulons
que les le repérage se fait le plus tôt
possible parce qu'il y a beaucoup
d'actions menées dans les collèges
passer dans les écoles et donc nous
voulons là aussi à renforcement des
actions de détection de prévention à
travers le système éducatif donc ça
c'est pour la première partie repérage
la deuxième partie c'est de sensibiliser
d'informer informer c'est quoi bah c'est
d'expliquer qu'il faut arrêter avec ça
on ne peut pas continuer avec une
société violente envers les femmes
envers les enfants
travailler contre les addictions drogues
et alcool
travailler sur tous ces sujets pour
renforcer la parentalité donc nous c'est
un axe fort de dire que nous voulons
sensibiliser informer aller vers les
familles et le troisième axe comme je
l'ai dit c'est de coordonner des actions
quoi mieux accompagner les victimes
chacun dans son domaine déployé plus de
moyens d'accueil notamment des places
dans les structures d'accueil des places
au sein des familles aussi d'accueil
donc ça aussi c'est le rôle du
département nous avons renforcé nos
moyens et nous avons posé dans le cadre
du plan de mandatuades
2021-2028 un axe majeur de travail pour
le département qui est de lutter contre
les violences Théâtra familiales en
particulier les violences faites sur les
enfants
un axe fort qui se traduit par un
soutien accru aux intervenants de
terrain le budget a été augmenté en
conséquence passant de 900 000 euros en
2021 à un million 200000 euros en 2022
[Musique]